yeah hello and welcome to this video
which is about round 11 right eleven of
this year's Talib co tournament the
level means three rounds to go so we are
closing in on the end of the stern with
the finish line so we had a couple of
really interesting games around 11 and
I'm going to first tell you about the
games that I'm not going to cover even
though they had their interesting
moments but we have to cut some things
so not interesting we had a draicon
Westleigh soul which was a complete
snoozer because under I can decided to
not do anything at all against South
London you know we had this we had this
line which we know from the World
Championship match as being like nothing
at all we had the couple of games like
this already so nothing happens in this
game absolutely nothing when we had the
game and avoid to check aronia and
that's what actually could interesting
what the shack was better most of the
time and got close to win but ultimately
Aronian managed to hold this game then
we have neptunia chi early enough that
was a clip on opening yeah not that
exciting I mean little it's not so
interesting are you not comparable to
this but I'm not going to include it in
the video so some other games were much
more interesting I'm going to start with
them a key moment of the game between it
should report and Luke friend Bailey I'm
alone typically of bead opening for
report and yeah interesting oven didn't
play a four-year set of 93 but we call
an interesting position really
unconventional as we as you could expect
like you want the good move trying for
this and yeah this is going to be a very
sharp game all of a sudden with white
pushing on the Kings side and black on
the queenside
this is what when Bailey went for
pushing the pawn all the way and yeah
the funny thing is that the move g5
taking this denied reports just answered
with capturing and g4 yeah he just
ignored the attack on the knife to open
up lines H and G file okay I'm not going
to advertise it in much detail I know it
looks it looks funky but we have lots of
things to to check later I want to go to
one key moment and I should really get
my notes because otherwise I'm not
understanding anything at all it's just
it just extremely sharp and okay to go
forward a little bit I know this looks
extremely extremely complicated and and
and tufted tufted says there's one
moment later and I want just want to
check and this is very typical very
typical and technical issue so this
position here report now as you could
see by my spoiler took on g7 let's have
a look at this this position it's um a
case where widely doesn't have all that
many moves yes the black queen and
threatening checkmate and the only other
move that makes any any sense bishop see
to this is in fact the better move but
it is quite quite instructed to see why
am this move placed on report does not
work so he took them the night captured
if the King takes white is actually
going to mate Queen g5 let's say here
rook age 7 and black is going to be
checkmated by the two heavy pieces so
nice captured and now he gave the check
on c7 and this now is some quite
instructive we almost automatically
assume that in the situation I exact the
king
has to move yeah of course I mean here
this is all time travel is short so when
Billy is down to two minutes and it
doesn't have much time to calculate it
but if you have more time you can figure
out then in fact instead of moving the
king he meant he went to g8 which is
going to be a via draw instead of going
with the king he can play Bishop d7 and
it says sometimes difficult to see such
a move here the main threat is still
still valid and white has to react to
that if he takes King g8 you should see
two like it's playing this and in fact I
mean it looks dangerous this check but
you can just go here now this is the
counter maid so to say you can check but
this is counter checking so tough tough
to see such a such a defense or in fact
this is the defense that actually wins
ultimately if why does not take in
mediately on the seven for example
playing this then you can actually move
the rope yeah and black is defending
note that there is an old saying the
light is the best friend of the king and
defense it's quite good that twin f5
smart working the night is indeed a good
defender it often locks those checks by
Queens those those nearby checks like on
f5 h5 and so on so here if we go back we
should be seven would have won the game
for when Valley after King g8 Bishop c 2
we should have five that's actually
necessary in the smoke here and it is a
it is a row k white has to now check
give a perpetual yeah you can never take
as the meydan be true so here they
really had a chance to to win the game
the next game I'm going to look at that
this is going to be in a bit more detail
it's the game of the world champion
magnus cows where is that game until
playing on bond by the way if you hear
weird noises that's because one of my
are my neighbors like down the street Oh
is the chopper harley and sometimes on
Saturdays he will ya get dis chopper out
and just like aimlessly drive around the
block I know it sounds crazy but it is
what it is and you always have those
those noises from the from the holidays
engine so it's quite a funny anyway
let's see what happens or that's here
would happen and the game Carlton honey
buns he has got money for and re bonds
is always always good for surprise these
places Scandinavian with Knight f6 not
the most popular opening but now how bad
can it be a probably just a slight edge
for white in the game nine f3 was played
maybe cousin was keen to avoid honking
lines like this is probably not the best
line ever but if you don't know it it
can be tricky now there are three is
some good conservative move to avoid
complications and this position type in
itself always should be a little bit
better for white in the game we had a
really interesting development I'm going
to fast forward a little bit 95 and I
want to Connie five interesting choice
you are not grabbing only two now here
Queen takes Knight takes pawn takes is a
typical position type that is almost
always a bit better for why due to the
space advantage that
5 on provides so he took with this if
now d takes d5 neck might preserve the
bishop and this is now in good piece so
Bishop takes h5 was Carla's choice and
the honey bun went to g6 okay we got
queen bee three often times and a good
idea for white whenever the bishop on c8
has left early and it's difficult for
black now to handle this to be seven
pond is attacked and you don't want to
play a passive more freely like this for
example that just doesn't help white
already has the bishop pair in the back
and if he can consolidate and yeah
complete development and so on like
group d 1 c phi is going to be fine if
they look p 8 and this is in fact
involving a sacrifice c19 f6 yeah and
causal went for it he Greg day seven tom
it's the kind of place that is playing
with fire the gym like it's much better
developed he does he has not yet
cancelled but he doesn't need to cancel
necessarily in this position as Luke is
already on a half-open far and wide
still is yes not doing anything on the
queenside we see that Bishop d6 and now
Bishop c7 gives our ebonic the attacking
idea yeah which is d 3 we had to do
something about it note that taking the
the pawn is not great because of Bishop
f4 in a position like this white is able
to push the five rook takes 23 is no
perpetual the Queen can always come back
and blacks King now feels a bit
uncomfortable this is not using or
anything but white is definitely better
this is a better move Queen d7 the idea
is that sometimes even be five and
twenty x h3 as a possible
so carbon quickly pushes the h-bomb he
is a pawn up but blacks position is
active and the cleaner a7 still needs to
lose time here we go 25 and now be five
played by Audubon let wants to
accelerate the play opening it up and he
has really nice compensation for this
pawn as we see rook c8 Queen moves again
and here yeah black is a porn down but
those two pawns are not going anywhere
anytime soon they're not really
effectively taking part in the game and
they can easily be taken by black at any
given moment when the pressure is
getting getting a little bit too serious
so here I'm Calvin basically had decided
to snatch the spawn and try to yeah
weather the storm but it is not a
comfortable position to play yeah those
moves Queen d2 if you have to play like
that it's not it's not nice so we're
going to go a little bit ahead 55
probably this isn't the best move d take
c5 is probably safer in a situation like
that black is active enough so for sure
I mean something like like this is a
pawn from white but it's going to be
extremely difficult to make something
serious happening this is probably what
thousands should have gone for he went
Bishop g5 always trying to find it can
rarely accuse them of not try to make a
slide out of games but here 90 form this
is already getting slightly
uncomfortable for what Lucas in 1 i've
got traded and now rupee 8 is a good
move the e-file is the good terms on
place to be for the book so look T 1 and
black took on before yeah we see that
black is extremely active he's looking
at the F to square the bishop also and
why currently and have to use the Queen
as a blockading piece which is really
really nice it's still nothing
too serious I mean black is better but
it's not them yet mostly anything who
should have form Knight f6 here the
computer points out the move Queen to d5
and this is it seems quite strong idea
the ideas amongst others to try to play
f6 and g5 pushing the bishop away this
is a very difficult move to find for a
human player one thing we have to notice
then why it can never take on deform
because of this trick a tactic that
everybody should know and and that I've
found myself to a lot yeah inlets that
I've lost my Creed and they countless
times to that tactic so um yeah oops and
the queen is gone okay clearly five was
an interesting and good move probably
but neither of six was played by the
Indian player and Calvin when tonight to
see 195 and here in this position target
only has one good news that you can play
it should play the move Queen jf three
after twin Jeff three he is probably
going to be okay note that the night is
also now ready to occupy the d3 square
which is a lot better no painting
concept than having the Queen there but
the main thing is what he did he played
this move this does basically loose now
to get to a black attack if light glaze
correctly re band played the move Queen
to c6 it's not a that's not a bad move
to say I mean it's not hurting back but
he had a very strong opportunity and
this is the move Queen to sorry if they
Queen to d4 and this is a move that now
can be evaluated very very clean way
because there is just a couple of
possibilities at all the look is hanging
why does not
have a decent move with the bishop if he
goes here there is some yeah that's the
same tactic that they're going to see
hit the other lines um yeah I I can show
you there's the move 93 and this is an
extremely strong rules now the rook is
attacked and if wise takes it yeah this
is falling okay and at the end like is
going to take this and the threat of e2
it's fantastically strong and there's
not much that one can do you could try
this okay yeah but you're not going to
survive this one thank you sir checking
with all his pieces let's look again
that was the bishop move but what about
animals he could move to look look as
one okay what has to take j okay and
again there's a threat of taking and e2
and that's impossible to survive what
about Queen to be three same story thus
more servants okay now I note that there
is this main idea and e2 and impossible
it's just the wind it's just a win for
black the best defense or the the one
that is its most interesting is rooting
you on this is also used but here at
least black has to find something
special the move Knight is three that
was winning against all the other moves
here does not win interestingly enough
because of the move Queen 32 yep looking
at the rook and please now after Queen
h3y can actually do this and now set up
in this is still fairly complicated
there for example black can go look c8
and try to enter here you have the
capture is still going to be quite
tricky okay this is all a bit of a moot
point because after Queen g41 black has
a sled win a clean win with the
fantastic move rookie three yes that's
that's really great yeah and yeah what
is why I supposed to do you can take it
in sometime in some ways and plan takes
you guys like us taking yeah and now
setting up this discoveries why this
without a defense so he can take this
but this is a winning attack it's just
too much going on Queen g2 made and yeah
actually take it yeah you're going to
lose the house as well okay just pick up
this so Queens you for would be one who
is free that's really an amazing move
and and this is a a bit similar to a
famous game buy elocon is set I think it
was right here right right Thiele kind
von barda's 25 we need to look that up
to be sure that this rookie three is the
bitter bit of them very reminiscent of
that game yeah White has no defense if
he takes with the bishop you just take
him and the thread she is extremely
strong if white takes we grab here and
everything is falling it's great it's
great Queen g4 was winning the game but
I leave on didn't do it he played 32 36
yeah and now in fact why it is ok again
and what is ok again it was really
dodged bullets here for causal Queen g4
was there's really no no repair after
that absolute
the end the game we had some
simplifications and they had reached to
a draw here so very lucky moment here
for the world champion he played with
high a little bit by taking the
polonaise heaven here in the opening I
think that it's an understandable
decision and you want to get some
imbalance going and this was the way to
do it however the risk was pretty high
and in the complications audubon header
had a winning possibility in general the
Indian players doing a great job in this
tournament that already said at the
beginning that it C will be interesting
to watch and I think that was quite
right with that his games are always
almost always going to be interesting to
watch so M next game I want to check is
Curie with white against pantani
harikrishna so we have an English
opening symmetrical English with black
playing a quick t5 and now give went in
for interesting this is the line that I
have played myself a couple of times and
in this line there has been a recent
relatively recent development night
before is the normal move black tries to
get this check into the picture we
should see form yeah my check and white
goes King into in this position it was
always believed that black only has one
real opportunity here to option to check
and go back to e6 here White has a
couple of interesting options the most
interesting one and also the move that I
had played in this position is the move
before I don't want to analyze they have
been a couple of games with this with
this line a game that I am a recall
offhand as the game between Levon
Aronian and two parlo played a while
back like maybe like two years ago or
something there is however an additional
idea or an idea that has been young
where the evaluation has changed
in recent years is the move and i take c
1 this is a move that at first sight
looks extremely risky because I mean
wife's development is fantastically
advanced guys got three pieces out the
route 1 C 1 the only thing that's kind
of wrong is the king of only two and
you're not having yeah you're not having
beforehand so it's a it looks a little
bit unconventional disposition however
again whites development is
fantastically strong the computer thinks
that black is fine they're basically but
i have to say that i have a hard time to
believe in in this as at least in a
practical game the black side is
extremely difficult to play and we see
what happens and how a christian allow
place a six amazing it looks extremely
slow but this is a way to stop any
things on b5 happening and black
sometimes Believe It or Not plays be
five and then root a7 d7 saudi for by
giving we follow our example of this has
been played before we should be five
look at 7d takes d5 I mean first glance
you think this is crazy for black and ya
still still they play it and the
computer does not really dislike it all
that much I mean it's something where I
mean I don't believe in that sorry I
don't believe in this position for black
and I probably would meet a lot more
time to check with the computer and why
does why this should be it should be any
good I mean like currently it will porn
down to you and he tries to to get it
back with these six thing is why does
not have to move the bishop now I
understand that if white now let's say
would play something like this that leg
might be okay yeah he might catch up
brooke d 7 for example quincy to we
should be seven this was stable again
vehicle bank only Pony achi
a couple of years back and black
actually won that game I understand that
this might be okay if you get c5 back
and you get the bishop pair with like
okay but I mean giving our plates e6 and
just yeah and left this Bishop on d5 for
the taking and I simply cannot believe
that this should be good for black how
accretion a plate played before after
some thought which is that ok quindi
form rooks is seven and nine is for this
is a this piece sacrificing on d5 is not
going to be justified by a by a concrete
tactic but have a look at this position
I mean there's a pawn on c6 supported by
the pawn on d5 white has two points for
the peace and blacks pieces here I
cannot move at all I all really cannot
believe that this should be good to be
honest and I find it a little bit a
little bit weird that somebody would
play into this with black I mean we have
to see that black hair skirt has to have
choices you can go to a four-year for
example it's just more solid okay maybe
this is just something that you wanted
to experiment with here Cara Krishna
would I completely hate this position
I'm not completely sure from from an
analytical point of view like if you
give it to a computer or played and
correspondence chess or whatever but
from a practical point of view I think
next position is fairly terrible he
played Bishop e7 you can also look at
which should be six what the engine is
is suggesting after a while which is not
a definite answer you need much more
time to get a full evaluation this is
what the engine gives I just want to
show the position yeah here now and it
gives a slight edge for white but you
know would you like to play this with
black I mean I take white here and I
mean like
minister in the game Bishop e7 was
played ok gimme took the pot and now we
had to know we had this check in this
position in fact the computer um gives
an interesting move that is very
difficult to understand that for us and
how we create I took on d5 is first of
all what what what we have to consider
after then why'd was completely winning
the computer alternatively note that
this Bishop is hanging I thought this is
what happened in the game yeah the
computer wants to play this move and
after night takes play Queen B 5 the
idea is that this is hanging and Queen B
5 with a check will pick up the night
but again look at this position yeah
white is going to click image to and use
the h1 rock this is this is not playable
I mean you are do you have zero
coordination your king is only eight and
those pieces are terrible it's just
funny a funny idea then to first give
the bishop and then go for this this is
Queen D 5v5 yeah this is our place and
Aguirre and go got the piece back here
which eight and h3 yeah again what one
is completely winning here no surprise I
mean if you choose check out why he's
two pawns up and the only thing that we
can definitely state is that this
position is quite murky yeah it's really
not very well well organized at safe and
okay age three what we also have to ask
ourselves what happens yeah if black
takes this white is going to play here
and then woke you one next the queen is
just too offside yeah like this this
next you try to save
six yes you're going to be killed like
that I played rupee six Queen a form and
yes the next one and this will get taken
off taken and give restoring it okay
everything is good ham he activates he
gets the King to g2 this is all nice but
a couple of moves later Here I am Here
you have an opportunity to win the game
straight away with the move Queen to F
form intending Quintus except it's
pretty nice but that's what the engine
is giving or you can have a less
computer ish solution with just taking
like Knight takes 94 that's also
excellent for white material is equal
now but blacks position is not
coordinated at all and the roof is going
to join the action pretty quickly
there's also winning this is want to
give it plate it doesn't look at like a
very natural but the thing is it has a
concrete problem Queen 83 played by Hari
Krishna which is a great move very good
move the main point is that it looks at
this night and would see quickly where
this is going to be very relevant now in
this position and white has to be very
precise the move that he plays this
actually loose believe it or not inflate
96 and 95 was probably still okay and
here Bishop d7 was played and we already
see that there is something going on on
f3 95 and this is the moment we are
literally I could have won but it is
them something that with two minutes on
the clock yeah it's tough to call it a
big mistake because you have no time the
move that he played looks very normal
when 36 which is not going to do it but
look these sequence that was extremely
strong the extremely
in the aesthetic point is that after 97
like has 95 it's really great I mean
just from a problem from the visual
point of you know the night takes one in
seven blocking the each file and then 95
is coming which is going to be going to
win the game on f3 yeah let's move like
it's actually taking with the night
threatening night you want double check
yeah I mean who's going to see that with
two minutes on the clock probably nobody
this was played and now everything is ok
again for White Queen 65 is correct and
thien hau attrition I took only one here
in fact give it could have won again but
this is a tough tough already night if
one is the most normal move but 26 was a
bit stronger threatening these
checkmates yeah it's about getting blank
a little bit more uncoordinated and only
then take this kind of thing is
extremely difficult extremely difficult
to figure out not impossible the
difficult he took only one immediately
and now after after this it seems that
between 85 or stronger but can't win a
two now again a king h2 was winning but
you know this is computer chess em they
now go to a position where there was
something else i'm sorry i forgot that
even in the end there are some muslim
tricks and king did not a freaking
disabled and now King h2o sped yes 96
year was a draw but give it a teenage to
and this actually does lose you too 22
mental played by Hari Krishna can I have
six kings to 795 and here they agree to
draw however
however if you would have gone to see
eight it seems that black is actually
winning the game there is some not much
that's going to be tried now for what is
the same and now what is he supposed to
do let's say what would happens if he
moves the night I didn't analyze that
let's say okay it looks bad young but
Queen to e7 now the thing is those poles
will win them all right like it's a poem
did you look at that all that much I
looked at the check which is going to be
answered by another by 98 sorry this yes
this then and now 98 and here we have a
double attack on f3 + f2 and check and
bishops is six and that's going to be
the end is super tough the same to see
so in one run up and down five year both
sides could have won it's very very
tricky to play such a technical position
with no time so very interesting name um
next game over the draw and we have all
kinds of drawers and next game and the
final game for the session for this
video is going to be ye kayaking and
then I've said it's all a mess yes we
got a balance with these three so
usually not to start something extremely
interesting but ye is coming up here was
an interesting piece of preparation
trade see three castles and in this
position while of course and usually
just castles but he has a very
principled continuation that is not seen
all that often and I always wondered
actually if there is something in this
these lines because never felt so
straightforward to me I mean not a lot
saying that like I knew it all along I
was just
when i was looking at this was black
years ago that that wasn't all that
clear to me but we're talking about 15
years ago so it's just something else or
10 years ago to something that I had in
mind when I saw the game Allison you who
I was thinking that this isn't so clear
okay what what did he do we took on on
96 pawn takes and grabbing the phone why
just takes the pond and this is this
never had the reputation to be extremely
problematic but as I said I always felt
like you this isn't all that clear to me
so what is black supposed to do and
first of all you have to react quite
quickly if you do something slow then
why'd is going to consolidate his pawn
let's say you play a croupier or some
white is going back and it's not clear
that you get the pawn back now something
like d5 there is any 5 and this doesn't
look like compensation at all the only
move that makes any sense is d5 that was
played directly opening it up I mean why
this neglecting development and of
course white cannot take on c6 because
of Queen e8 yeah that looks immediately
awkward this is hanging there is 94 and
so on and that isn't very good but
interesting is to move the form which
was played by rahim yeah bishop is
hanging it done when to be 69 takes e4
is also a possibility okay I don't want
to analyze the whole line but okay the
sampled and now he is cancelled and the
pawns took only for all this has been
played before we see that kayak can
spend lots of time this one line is
probably not yes not what was probably
not part of his his regular preparation
of things that he regularly looked at
and
a good surprise by the Chinese player
Ted Bishop g5 and see 50 logical p.m.
like always have to be aware that if he
is not careful it could happen I mean he
has to be absolutely yea merrily used to
allow that but it could happen if white
would get in like before a three and
keep this Bishop on b6 incarcerated that
it can never move because I wanna run
then I don't imagine a problem before
you cannot go here you cannot go here
and there are the own pawns I'm drawing
badly not this one okay yeah so c5 is a
strategically very desirable move that
makes the bishop active again yeah 92
all this has been played the form and
now I'm kayaking on place a new move but
it was certainly not prepared a novel
team it was just you have someone trying
to like say reinvent the wheel a little
bit he took on d4 it seems that this
rule was already leading into into a
serious trouble the move that has been
played before he was Bishop d7 in the
Grand Master Kim I found the game
between a shower bar lock and accounting
knowledge from 2011 when fake balog also
got the better position but there are
probably a couple of opportunities to
improve white and took on c5 late night
be three we have a position where white
has the better pawn structure black has
the bishop pair and interesting the
interesting position in the game he took
on the form challenge what the heck no
challenges please so she takes the form
and night text before and now we see
that there is enormous pressure on the
f6 porn air for on their 69 the main
idea is Queen f3 it's already
pickle to give black some advice he took
and he took it on c3 which is probably
relatively bad without the Queen f3 you
just in trouble interesting that why you
spend so much time then looks like a
fairly natural move and should be proud
of prep okay anyway I did I didn't check
the clock times before the form I just
don't get the moves not the clock times
while analyzing yeah black ian has a big
problem f6 is just under under severe
pressure and it seems that you only have
the choice between what kind of worse
position you have to play and Bishop d7
looks like the only move cdc2 xb2 it's
just not working yeah threatening mate
so this is the white takes you should be
for has to be played Queen takes and now
black has the choice take with the pawn
take with the Queen and yeah if you take
it upon the danger is that you're just
going to get checkmated because your
king position is extremely weak I think
white is also clearly better here after
naija form if black takes on b2 now
after hook the one that's going to be
extremely tough to defend probably
impossible to then computer only gives
I'm sorry after this gives the move f5
forever here after night h6 yet and
these moves blacks position looks
terrible yeah he hasn't completely
wrecked porn structure and the night is
not that bad on h6 because it has a
clear path back into the game so here I
see ya yeah just white being clearly
better it seems like he's already in big
trouble probably you can already blame
that he takes the form wolf I don't
he is going to get a good position
anymore in the game kayak took with the
Queen which avoid the checkmates of the
slim as the King now is safe but of
course you're running into 97 which is
just a four so Queen g6 and now buddy is
quickly going into this ending yeah
intermediate move so at least you get a
pawn but here this is a nice little
mafia not automatically taking on be too
this is what often happens to a club
player for amateur players they they
kind of see okay I have to take the pawn
right anyway let's take the pond but you
have an intermediate move the pawn is
not going to run away and if you take
here and black get throught the eighth
it's just not as good now black have
some options so and you can just occupy
this file and then take this next rook
e8 and also claimed in the game actually
no king e7 but if you clip where you can
still play this to cover this or if you
take you also have this covered so
you're sure that you're not giving up
any central file can you seven would be
too yeah this ending is technically
winning four wide as the sea porn is so
far back and black LexA coordination in
a little bit it it's actually a bit
surprising how quickly kya can do this
this but it's probably lost anyway you
can reach go fast forward he resigned
it's impossible now to defend at seven
after one of those rumors yeah so a
great win for vallière out of out of
good preparation I think he somehow
managed to found find a line that
kayaking did not really have on the
radar which was a bit surprising I mean
this is a certainly was a key part of
his opening prep for the World
Championship match but sometimes it
happens you forget something or you kind
of confuse things so why eat with a good
win this actually sets up an interesting
situation where say so is still leading
the tournament
but my emails only have a point behind
and in round 12 ye is actually playing
so so an interesting matchup if IE wins
this game is going to overtake him and
taking the lead in this event would be
certainly fantastic for the Chinese
youngster but ok it's got the black
pieces and so has lost in like ages like
50 games or so will be difficult yeah I
hope you enjoyed the coverage around 11
I'm going to be back with round 12
coverage probably late on Saturday
thanks for watching